technology has given us so many gifts
but one thing it has robbed us of is the
ability to remember phone numbers
apparently southern living reports that
we are in a code red situation
no one remembers or even tries to
remember phone numbers anymore
it's so true i remember i wonder if you
guys do too
all my friends from middle school i
still to this day i could call them
right now if you gave me like a phone i
could dial
100 i'll i swear i would give them to
you right now but you probably call them
but i do i would but my fiance's phone
number
i couldn't tell you what it is
shut up you don't know wellington's
phone number no i think it starts with a
three
but he's number one in my heart you guys
he is but
oh my god you are
the living example of this story because
back in the day we used to have to call
people and dial the number and now you
just push wellington you just push drew
you know so you don't have to memorize
okay i've been working on making sure um
my daughters know the phone numbers the
addresses all of that kind of emergency
stuff because the point of this article
was what happens in an emergency i have
no i really have no idea what i would do
well and i love that drew plans for
emergency she has a landline yeah uh-huh
in the house for emergencies right
yes but here is the thing that just
peeves me to no end
oh god you really want to see me work
myself up into a lather oh god did i
bring up the landline okay why you did
so it turns out now
land lines are connected to your cable
and guess what the cables attach to
digital and guess what digital is it is
not a landline so if your power goes out
your phone goes out
do you bring this kind of stuff up on
dates
you know what bugs me is my landline
that's what bugs me
well i would say if any guy would reject
me for that then you know c'est la vie
est
well here's another
relationship question oh i love this
story
you know people are dating people in
relationships and if you are dating
there's a new term called dawn dating
d-a-w-n metro reports more singles are
mingling as the sun comes up they're
opting for early morning coffee dates
okay they say here are the benefits it's
alcohol-free that's a benefit um
i don't drink and i even i'm like
bottomless brunch exists
for a reason but they say it's also you
in the morning dawn dating you feel
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed going in
and there's a time limit you both have
to be on with your day at some point so
you can cut it short if you're not
feeling it yeah i don't like it
really i don't no not at all and i i
maybe for you good for you if it works
but if
no if somebody asked me ross you want to
go out on a date and i was like yeah and
they're like you want to meet at ihop
no
[Applause]
no
i i don't
i would i like to party early like
i don't drink but you know i'm not sober
and like i if i like i'm going to vegas
with a bunch of girlfriends and like i
want to just like start partying at like
10 a.m and like go hit the slots and
like the blackjack table like we're
going to like some shows and they start
at like 8 30 at night and i'm like i'm
not going to make it till 8 00. we're
not going to make it until 8 30. like i
like to be in bed by 6 p.m with my food
on my thing yeah like done you and i are
on the same
timetable let me tell you but it's just
about meeting somebody i'm not that
interesting that early in the morning
you know what i mean but some people you
know they like a morning situation so
why you know if you're up for that why
not uh you know just saying
well someone's an early bird
[Music]
you